andr display looks at Donald Trump he
says Donnie there wasn't enough cream
cheese and the bagels in the gradual the
president says Andrew whose problem is
that he says it's your problem Donnie
it's your problem
Andrew you're fired well this is not
happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. some say it
only lasts 15 minutes some people are
gonna tell you it's a mythical creature
that lives at the bottom of the rainbow
some will tell you not to overdo it
[Music]
yes me I say enjoy while it lasts
we've been living in the game
[Music]
talking politics but it's hard for me to
not talk politics when I'm on stage
doing stand-up because I know the
president and that's my story today I
[Applause]
know the president I know the President
of the United States he fired me on the
Celebrity Apprentice he screamed at me
when he fired me he didn't scream at the
other celebrities he didn't scream at
Brian McKnight
whoever the that is there's a good
guy he's a good guy
the president fired me you know I
watched the Celebrity Apprentice I used
to watch that show and I thought I could
win that I could win that business
competition so when they asked me to do
the show I thought this is great I'm
gonna do the Celebrity Apprentice I'm
gonna win this thing and I studied the
show I studied all the strategy I got
the tapes I was gonna win this thing
episode one I showed up I didn't know
who the other celebrities were gonna be
in walks my good friend Andrew Dice Clay
one of the great stand-up comedians in
history and my good friend I'd known
Andrew Dice Clay for ten years he used
to come to my internet television show I
was doing an Internet TV show on the
Internet from my living room yeah my
career was going pretty well
immediately when Andrew often I thought
okay this is gonna throw my whole
strategy out the window because whenever
I'm hanging out with Andrew Dice Clay
we like to mess around with people we'll
get in fake arguments just to confuse
people around us so in the first episode
of the Celebrity Apprentice season two
the president gave us a challenge we had
to make cupcakes I guess the president
figured that would be a good business
competition so I'm making cupcakes with
Andrew Dice Clay we start messing with
the people around us Andrew gets mad he
says Tommy you're not putting enough
sugar in the batter say calm down Andrew
calm down just wink black and Scott
Hamilton are looking at us wow these
guys really seem to know each other so
now we had an alliance against us right
Andrew Dice Clay and I were too familiar
Clint black didn't like me country star
Clint black I don't want to say anything
bad about Clint black but that guy's a
asshole
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so we finish our cupcake challenge we go
to the boardroom everyone hears that
we've been yelling at each other the
President of the United States says to
Andrew Dice Clay Andrew I hear there was
a problem today Andrew Dice Clay looks
at Donald Trump he says Donny there
wasn't enough pre cheese and the bagels
in the greenroom
the president says Andrew whose problem
is that he says it's your problem Donny
it's your problem
Andrew you're fired so now my friend my
only Ally is fired I'm all alone with
Jesse James Clint Black Hershel Walker
and Dennis Rodman
episode 2 Olympic gold-medalist figure
skater Scott Hamilton is the project
manager our task is to make a commercial
campaign for a shoe company that starts
with the letter Z okay
doesn't matter which one but it starts
with the letter Z he suggests to us that
we do a campaign called e-e-e energy
enthusiasm excitement I look at Scott
and I say that's the stupidest
idea I've ever heard
this did not ingratiate me to my team
members we lost the challenge we go into
the boardroom I don't know if you're
familiar with the rules the apprentice
but the President of the United States
says to Olympic figure skater Scott
Hamilton Scott you get to fire one
person who are you bringing into the
boardroom today you can bring two people
into the boardroom who are you bringing
in and Scott Hamilton says mr. Trump I
know I can bring two people into the
boardroom but I'm only bringing one
person in the boardroom and that's Tom
because Tom deserves to get fired
he says fine and we walk into the
hallway and we wait around and the other
cast members leave and then we go back
into the boardroom I look at the
President of the United States
I say I know mr. Trump that Scott
doesn't think I did a very good job but
I think the reason that we lost this
challenge was because his idea was to
call the campaign EEE
starts with a Z and that's a stupidest
idea I've ever heard and Donald Trump
looked at me said you know Tom I think
you're right Scott your fire not bitter
or anything but I was 8 years ago I'm
fine now
episode 3 the President of the United
States walks away so now we're going to
decide who is the project manager this
week for each team was the men versus
the women I raise my hand I say mr.
Trump I would like to be the project
manager our whole team looks at each
other they say fine on the ladies side
the late great legendary Joan Rivers
[Applause]
she is the project manager for the
ladies
then mr. Trump the president says okay
your challenge this week is who can sell
the most wedding dresses who do you
think is gonna sell more wedding dresses
me and Dennis Rodman or Joan Rivers and
Khloe Kardashian so needless to say
things didn't go well my entire team now
had a alliance against me they mutiny
everyone had a job Clint Black was
supposed to do the promotion in
marketing he didn't do it Brian McKnight
was supposed to do some stupid thing who
didn't do it we lost the challenge at
the end of the day after working hard
trying to sell wedding dresses Dennis
Rodman leaned to me and he said hey Tom
ya want to go out for a drink so I went
out for a drink with Dennis Rodman the
president fired me because I went out
drinking with Dennis Rodman on the night
I was the project manager I mean this is
why sometimes I question the president's
judgment I mean what he is supposed to
do you're a kid from Canada you're in
New York City a seven-foot-tall
cross-dressing basketball champion asks
you out on a date
you say yes it's Dennis Rodman
[Applause]
and Dennis Rodman the guy's a legend
he's probably gonna pick you up take you
out for a steak dinner you head out for
a night on the town you have some
cranberry vodka so you hit the strip
club at the end of the evening you head
back to the hotel if you're lucky
doesn't have sex with you it's what I
call a backcourt violation
okay so basketball joke I don't know I I
guess I guess there's a Canadian
sometimes I feel odd talking politics
during this strange year in America you
know I mean at the end of the day what
do I got to do with it right I know
things could go bad but if things really
go bad I'm just gonna move home to
Canada we're building a wall gonna make
Donald Trump pay for it but if I can say
one thing I will say that it does
demystify the presidency when you know
the president I know the president
personally the president knows me anyone
who knows me should probably not be
president hey thank you very much
everybody